what's up guys bang bang this video is
brought to you by prime
xbt they are a crypto trading platform
that has an
excellent award-winning environment for
margin trading
if you want to go check out their crypto
trading be sure to check out their copy
trading module which allows you to
replicate the trades of the most
successful traders with a proven track
record
if you're interested you can register
with the link below and you can get a 50
deposit bonus go check them out at prime
xbt
and let's get into this interview
all right guys bang bang i've got a
special treat for you i've got mateo
here thank you so much for doing this
sir
oh thanks for having me i'm happy and
excited
all right let's go through your
background before you started ate sleep
you had like two or three other lives
uh you did not grow up in the united
states and then you've built a number of
other companies kind of walkers just
through your background
yeah so when i was a teenager i was an
athlete i was playing tennis tournaments
that is how i was spending my life and
then graduated in law uh joined two
large law firms
um and then i became an entrepreneur
started two companies both of them they
were in
solar so in renewable energy climate
change
and then i got into health and
performance again with aids like
all right and where were you doing the
other companies in italy
one in europe one in the us got it
and so when you start eight sleep the
general idea
is sleep fitness i want to start there
just what is
sleep fitness yeah so
we are really trying to reinvent the
concept of sleep sleep is not something
passive that you have to do and is a
waste of your time
sleep is like going to the gym it's
something you need to do
to be healthy to be fit so go to bed
take your time recover let your body and
your mind recover
so then in the morning you will be fit
and you will perform at your best
um there is a tagline that we use for
eight sleep that is
we fuel human potential through better
sleep
and so when you think through that i
think most people say okay i have to
sleep for eight hours i wish i didn't
have to sleep for eight hours
uh i'm not doing anything productive
talk
through kind of how you
you know and uh alex and and uh your
third co-founder when you went to go
start a sleep like what was the general
idea of what you could do
to actually improve this for people
yeah so there are two things we really
want to do we want to compress
sleep and we want to save your life
compressed sleeping means what if you
could sleep only six hours
and get more rest than when you were
sleeping eight hours
and then i can tell you how we can do
that but so we want to give you two
hours back
of your life every day second
because it's still six hours which is a
lot of time
how can we make that time productive we
will scan your body
in order to identify early signs of
illness
like even cancer so going to bed will be
more valuable than going to your doctor
every night it will be like going to
your dog
so when you think let's start with kind
of compressing time first right
um everyone is told since they're a
little kid get eight hours get eight
hours
um and the thought process is you need
eight hours of sleep because that
is what allows you to actually recover
and kind of let the body do what it
needs to do
how do you think you could compress that
from eight hours to six hours yet have
people
just as rested or more rested than they
are today
the reality is when they tell you oh you
need eight hours
it's sort of [ __ ] and sorry for for
for the world
the point is we don't use technology to
enhance our sleep
right and so we go to bed and we expect
to wake up refreshed
and more or less rule of thumb you need
eight hours
but the reality is this so you will get
around 20
rent if you are lucky you could range
between 17 and 25
call it 20. you will get 20 of deep
sleep
again 17 to 25 but let's call it 20 plus
20.
60 of your time or 50 of your time is
light sleep
light sleep is an inefficiency
of your body you don't really need it
what you need really need is ram
for your mind and deep sleep for your
body to recover
so our goal is to compress the amount of
light sleep
and if we cut that in a half that is how
we gain two hours
okay so let's talk a little bit about
there's rem
there's deep sleep and there's light
sleep when you go to sleep what happens
to the body
yeah so the first part of the night is
around
is about deep sleep deep sleep is
usually what you need to really recover
at the physical level your body then
once your body has recovered the second
part of the night will have a prevalence
of ram
premium studies for your mind this is
the moment where all the informations
that you have received during the
previous day that's
you know reorganized and saved in your
brain
rem is also when you dream um
and so the body gives first
most of the tension too deep because the
physical body needs to recover
and then only once that is done it gets
more into
into ram but the reality is you go
through cycles
or 90 minute cycles of light sleep deep
and ram
but the percentages change based on what
i just told you
and so in those cycles you're literally
going
from light to deep to rem um
is it good or bad to have more
or less cycles right like is it
something where if i go through
three cycles then that's okay but if i
got five cycles it's better
or it's just one cycle okay
at the end of the day what you need is a
certain amount of deep parameter
and usually the cycles tend to be quite
standard so around the 90 minutes
unless you have some special dysfunction
um
and so the the the key at the end of the
day is to get this 20
plus deep sleep out of the tower so you
can translate that in minutes
and the same for ram so for example in
my case if i get anything below
18 to deepen ram i start struggling
during the day
i'm not in my peak performance anything
above 20 percent
i'm like a lion and and i i i didn't get
anything done that day
so that is what really matters and the
amount of light sleep is
still just in inefficiency of your body
okay and so when you think through this
kind of
company mission of we want to compress
the amount of time that you sleep
you mentioned compressing the amount of
light sleep so not really touching
deep sleep or rem uh but cutting from
maybe four hours to
two hours right in terms of this light
sleep
is it possible to extend or kind of
elongate
the deep sleep and the rem as well so
you almost get uh
some of it is compressed on the light
sleep side but also elongating the time
for deep in rim
yes and no meaning the key for us is for
you to achieve
this let's call it 20 just faster
once you have the 20 you feel great you
don't really need more than that
and so the key is how do we get you
there faster
and so we will help you fall asleep
faster we will help you get deep sleep
sooner
rather than later and we will try to
extend that percentage
um across these 90 minute cycles
got it and you are literally like the
most for the foremost expert i know on
sleep uh i
uh as many people now know at the uh
throughout 2020 spent a bunch of time
trying to figure out how to get better
sleep
um i am a full-on convert if this was a
religion like i would be
all in uh i would go to church every day
and tell people like yes sleeping more
absolutely has this positive impact on
your body and your mind
what are some of the tips and tricks
that you think through in terms of
uh helping people get better sleep
but not products that you provide so is
there things that they can do
uh with their lifestyle before bed or
maybe even during sleep that they can
actually
get better sleep or get more rest
yeah so outside our products right what
everyone can do
so first if you talk to any sleep doctor
the first thing they would tell you
is sleep consistency so try to go to bed
at the same time
more than anything wake up at the same
time every day
even on saturday and sunday because if
you just sleep in
you're just jet lagging your body and
then on monday you will struggle again
to wake up
well instead what you want to do is you
want to train your body to wake up
every single day at that time doesn't
matter what the time is
it just needs to be always the same and
then if you can try to go to bed at the
same time but on that you can be more
flexible
then second thing is what i call
thermal shocks so one thing i do and i
love
is you could do a shower and you keep
switching between
hot and cold 10 times 30 seconds hot
30 seconds cold this thermal shock
will really help you relax at least of
this very personal but with me works
really well
another option that you have if you have
access to that is a sauna
and an ice bath but even just a shower
works great um orange lights
so i have philips hue and my house you
can set what are called routines
and so starting at 7 30 my lights start
dimming down and they're firstly
switched to orange
and then they keep dimming down and by 9
30 there is no more light
in in my house and so orange lights
helps you develop a melatonin and the
fact that lights keep dimming down will
help you understand that no
time for bad but time is coming
you can try some supplements you can use
melatonin
i use it from time to time some people
use cbd
or you could also try magnesium
magnesium will not have a direct
impact on your sleep but it will help
you relax your muscles
and then personally i do some mobility
exercises before going to bed
uh for for the hips for the body just
kind of not relax and open up your body
before you spend eight hours
on the bed yeah and so
each one of those things i think uh
could have a positive impact alone but
when you put them together obviously it
can be
quite um advantageous the one thing i
didn't hear you mention but i know we've
talked about before is just
like actually tiring yourself out during
the day to go to sleep
talk a little bit about if you do that
like what the advantage for that is
yeah a couple of things yeah the the
best way is
yeah you you want to work out or you
really want to make sure you're tired
but one thing i notice on my body is if
for example i work out
later in the afternoon or in the early
evening then you reactivate your body
and then my sleep is not that good so if
you can
try to work out in the first part of the
day
or by lunchtime but don't do it at 6 00
pm 7 p.m or 8 p.m
because otherwise that will reactivate
your heart rate so it will take time for
your heart rate to really stabilize and
relax again
you will start producing more heat which
will make more difficult for your body
to fall asleep
the other two big things that have an
impact on your sleep are caffeine and
alcohol
caffeine the rule of thumb is stop
drinking
it eight hours before going to bed then
our data shows that
everyone is different so you might you
know
suffer caffeine more than i do or vice
versa so
test it and the last one is alcohol i
stopped drinking
in april 2018
you know we spoke about that alpha has
an impact on deep sleep on ram
on your body temperature hrv and also
your heart rate at rest
explain more about the alcohol because i
don't think people really understand
this right there's a lot of people who
say oh when i get drunk then i pass out
and i
fall asleep it's amazing but what's kind
of happening from a physiological
standpoint when you put alcohol in your
body before you try to sleep
yeah so from a physiological standpoint
you have this sense where oh it's gonna
relax my mind
my mind stops from racing and then i can
fall asleep
but the reality is the quality of sleep
that you will get
is low quality and so in the morning
when you wake up your hrv
which is a heart rate variability and
it's a good metric to determine how
rested you are
um would just be lower than expected
because that has an
impact on on your heart rate as well the
other big thing is
uh in particular as you get older you
will see that alcohol has an impact on
your body temperature
and so if i drink um i will start
feeling hot
in the middle in the middle of the night
and so that will be
an additional thing that will impact my
sleep quality
so overall you don't feel it you just
think that it's relaxing you but at the
end of the day the type of
sleep you get is poor so you stopped
drinking in april 2019
uh i haven't drank all of january uh
we're recording the shorts into january
and i feel amazing uh definitely has
improved my sleep so
so i can kind of speak to that but you
still drink coffee and so how do you
think about
caffeine in general for you do you drink
in the morning and then you stop at a
certain time do you limit yourself to
how much you drink
yeah so i'm italian and so i drink
espresso
and i drink three espressos that more or
less they are the equivalent of one cup
of coffee
american coffee and i have one early in
the morning
around nine then i have one around 11
30 and the last one by two one thing i
started doing because i wanted to reduce
the caffeine intake
was to switch to decaf and so i still
have 3s
espresso but they have decaf and so
usually with the decaf you are just in
taking one third of caffeine
compared to a regular coffee and so at
the end of the day
something like if i was having only one
espresso for the whole day
that's super interesting um and then you
mentioned working out
as something you do in the morning is
there certain types of exercises that
are better or worse
uh for sleeping should i think about it
in terms of
uh running or other cardio type
exercises versus weightlifting or is it
all kind of the same as just burning
calories
so for for sleep itself it's probably
all the same
at least we don't have data about that
yet
what i can tell you is when you think in
terms of longevity for your
body um you should think in in three
dimensions the first one is high
intensity interval training
so spike your heart rate as much as you
can let it drop spike it again
you will see incredible results
immediately in your biometrics
even if you just use an apple watch you
will be impressed
second you want to do weight training so
you want to really
build the muscles there is plenty of
medical evidence
that weightlifting is really good
for for for your longevity and for your
body long term
and the third one is mobility so you
want to make sure as you get
older that you maintain a a good
mobility
which will be extremely key when you
start getting no into the 70s or 80s
yeah makes uh makes sense so we've
talked a lot about uh what you can do
kind of during the day um or before bed
uh you at eight sleep really solve the
problem of
what people can use at night right and
kind of what are the products that you
could actually use
uh to get better sleep maybe walk us
through just what that product suite
looks like today
yeah so the biggest factor impacting
your sleep quality which we didn't
mention yet
is temperature 50 of the couples they
fight around temperature
and the reason is uh it's pretty simple
temperature is different from for each
of us
when you hear people saying oh you
should sleep at 68 degrees
is wrong and the reason is your body
temperature changes during the night
and so the temperature of the
environment and the temperature of the
bed
need to change accordingly so a fixed
temperature will never work
it will not work for you it will not
work for your wife it will not work
for myself and so that is what we
developed we developed a technology
that changes the temperature of your
body during the night
based on your biometrics and there is
medical evidence that
through temperature adjustment we can
improve
usually performance you can fall asleep
faster
you can get up to 20 more deep sleep you
can get more ram
and our data shows that we are also
reducing custom turns
and wake ups by 30 to 40 percent
so 96 percent of our customers are
reporting better sleep
with our product and so when you think
about
how the product works i have one uh it's
amazing
um i sleep colder than plano sleeps
but how does the product itself actually
worked there's a mattress
there's a pod cover but just walk us
through kind of like what those products
actually are
yeah so there are two form factors you
can buy the whole mattress
and they call it the lamborghini of the
mattresses or the sleep performance
and then there is the mattress cover so
you can retrofit
any dumb the mattress let's say you
don't want to change your mattress you
like it you just bought it
you just want to put our technology on
top of it
now you can do it technology is the same
across the two devices
and it does two main things first
dynamic temperature control so we can
change the temperature of your body
during the night and each side of the
battery can have a different temperature
second the technology comes with
embedded sensors
so we are able to track everything about
your heart rate your respiration
and your sleep and so when
you've got the temperature regulation
going on it's basically taking water
and it's putting it through this uh kind
of cover
right and uh that's what is being
chilled or
uh potentially even heated in some
situations
yeah so the temperature can range
anywhere between 55 degrees and
100 degrees it can be really cold or
really hot 90 percent of our customers
they are kind of in the middle
so they don't need that extreme
temperature some customers
love to get into bed and find it
extremely cold
usually men like not to find the bed
really cold while instead
women like to find it warmer but
obviously it depends it depends on
your of the gender on your body fat on
your age
for example women in menopause they have
hot flashes and so they want
the cold bed so we are able to adjust
based on all these different needs but
the other key thing is
we will change the temperature during
the night and so usually
as soon as you fall asleep we'll try to
cool you
and in the second part of the night when
you tend to have more rep
we will try to provide a thermal
neutrality
the reason is this when you are in rem
you're dreaming right
and so your brain deactivates a lot of
body functions
including temperature control if your
brain
feels that the environment is too hot or
too cold
it will not let you get into rem because
you could
die if you were like in a store right
and so the key for rent is thermal
neutrality where your brain
understands that the environment is safe
and it can let you
fall into ram and so when this is
happening how much of this
is uh i have to be a genius and
understand my body and set the
temperature
and also the different times through the
night correctly versus you'll tell me
uh kind of proactively hey many people
like you are likely to
want you know plus or minus degrees at
certain times in the night
yeah so there are two tiers right right
now we are in
in the first year and the first theory
is about
suggesting you what you should set as a
temperature right so
this is the recommended temperature for
people of your gender and this age
plus we see environment uh environmental
changes so let's say that the weather in
miami changes we will provide a
different recommendation
but the end goal that is going to come
in a couple of months
is temperature autopilot that is one of
the most requested features
and so we will be able to control the
temperature for you
so yes set it and forget it we will
maximize the
temperature for you and then in the near
future there will be different
modes or profiles where you will be able
to say look i want to optimize
this thing let's say a lower heart rate
that is what we will be able to do it
to do for you through machine learning
and ai
yeah it's and it's super smart right
because basically you've got this
product
out uh with all the customers you're
gathering data because the sensor's in
the bed
uh you've got a very slick kind of uh
mobile phone
uh application and uh over time you're
just
learning right it's very similar you
know i've talked before about like tesla
and the fact that they've got all these
cars on the road and they're just
gathering data and so they're so
far ahead than everyone else with the
data that that ends up being a pretty
significant advantage
yeah we're collecting i mean we have
already collected several millions
hours of sleep right and the database
keeps growing
obviously we are in compliance with you
know all all the rules anonymized and
aggregated data
but yeah we are learning we are becoming
one of the largest
split databases in the world and based
on this data
we can become better and better at
optimizing your sleep
so for the people that use the existing
products
either the mattress or the mattress pod
what is the kind of you know normal
response to people is it longer sleep is
it deeper sleep
what are some of the things that you see
in the data uh that people
get as a benefit so the most
obvious already today are they are
falling asleep faster
and they are getting more
quality of sleep in particular we are
reducing costs and turns
and we are reducing wake ups by up to 40
percent
so a really meaningful number and so
they really have this you know
higher sleep efficiency i would say so
they can wake up
more rested in the morning i want to
talk about
the future products and some of the
things that you think that you guys will
be able to do over time
so today you've got things that make you
sleep better but you mentioned already
there's a whole nother kind of mission
to the business
and your vision which is being able to
turn the time that you are asleep into
more productive time
talk a little bit about kind of what
you're envisioning and hoping to build
uh in that perspective
yeah so first we want to reinvent the
form factor of the bed
to me is unacceptable that with
millions of people are still sleeping on
a piece of dumb foam that has been the
same for 2000 years
but that doesn't work so the
the way your bed looks will be different
soon
and we will start controlling a lot of
different environmental factors
not just temperature we will control
everything to optimize your sleep and
make sure that you can sleep faster
real quick when you say you're going to
change the uh kind of the
shape of the bed or the or the bed as an
actual form factor
i don't know how much you want to talk
about what exactly you're going to do
but just give people a sense like
are you going to try to turn the bed
from laying horizontal to vertical and
people are going to stand up and sleep
or what
how do you think about that yeah
it's tricky between what i can say or
what i cannot say
what i would say is this we want to
control all the environmental factors
that impact your sleep quality so we
want to have your back
while you're asleep and we want to make
sure that we help you sleep faster
that we track your health and we also
help
your body to regenerate and sleep and
live longer
and this is connected to the second
piece that is the health piece
the beauty of what we do is we have a
lot of space because the mattress is
pretty big and our aov is high
so adding sensors for 20 bucks or 40
bucks is not going to move our margins
this means that we can keep adding
sensors that are valuable for our users
in order to be able to track more
biometrics
and have a better understanding of their
health
a friend of mine no she just recently
lost
her dad because he had cancer and they
discovered this cancer a couple of
months before
he ended up dying that to me is
unacceptable
right now we don't have any control in
what is going on in our body
and so i want to solve and fix that
problem and there is a product that is
your bad that you use
every single day for 10 years and so
you're you're you know sleeping there so
you're not moving a lot
you're resting and so it's the perfect
environment to scan your body every
single day
for the next 10 years and we will see
how you are aging
and we will see if there is any early
sign of cancer or any other disease
and so when you think through that is
this something that
you'll be able to scan and you'll like
stream
to a doctor is it something where uh
you'll be able to tell maybe variations
of the biometrics and then just tell
people hey something seems to be off you
should go see a doctor like how do you
kind of
look at people basically taking the
information that you're able to
monitor and glean and actually turn it
into something that might be uh useful
for them
yeah i mean there are a lot of rules and
regulations and will be in compliance
with that
but oversimplified the laughter so what
what you just saved right the key will
be to see if there is anything off
compared to your baselines and if there
is we will
notify you and we will give you the
advice to go and talk to your doctor
the end goal is not to replace the
doctor we actually want to enable the
doctor
to have much more data about what is
going on in your health and be
able to act sooner rather than later to
save your life
yeah i'm a huge fan uh
as are many people on the internet and
it seems like you guys have been able to
build
uh somewhat of a cult following um
obviously if you help people sleep
better maybe it's just they're in a
better mood
uh and so they naturally have this
affinity for your product
but also you have this kind of
aspirational
goal and mission in terms of not only
making people sleep better but also
helping them to live healthier longer
lives on top of that
what do you think is driving that kind
of cult following online and is there
anything specific that you guys have
done
that was more intentional to kind of
help build up that
that following and that loyalty and
engagement
yeah i think we did a couple of things
first
we have a very different perspective of
sleep it's not a sleep like being comfy
on a sunday morning with waffles on your
bed
is not us and that is not me right we
are about performance we are about
okay this is time to recover it's like
going to the gym it's gonna be eight
hours today
hopefully less in the future but this is
a moment where you need to take care of
your body
then perform at your best and i don't
think there is any other company that
thought of sleep like a sort of fitness
and that is why
we invented the name click fitness that
is one
and i think second is i really think we
are a two percent of our product vision
and customers start understanding that
we
are a cutting edge technology company we
are not a mattress company we are not a
mattress cover company
we are really trying our best to
introduce technology to enhance our
recovery and sleep
and i don't think there is anyone else
there there are
wearables and and they're doing a great
job
but i think wearables they stop at the
data
they just try to recommend you something
based on the data the difference in our
case
is we are going to do the job for you
while you are asleep
our machine learning models are they're
working for you to optimize using
performance so we
are into this together and we will keep
developing technology
to improve your life and give you two
hours of life back
per day and so when you think about
giving that two hours of life back
is the idea that uh people will be awake
and functional and can kind of go do
other things
is it no it's gonna take an hour to get
ready for sleep and kind of you know
actually fall asleep and
take an hour to wake up and kind of like
one of those alarm clocks that almost
uh you know slowly wakes you up with
light and sound
um how do you kind of think about that
two-hour savings and what people will do
with it
so the i think the end goal is to really
give you two hours back that you can
spend with your loved ones or that you
can spend doing whatever matters
to you at the end of the day i mean the
whole point of how the company started
is because i started wondering why do i
need to sleep eight hours
can i sleep four hours and work harder
or do other things
and that is when i started reading you
know clinical papers
and i understood that the eight hours is
not written anywhere that we need eight
hours
we need that amount of different rent
and so to me
is if we can make our bodies more
efficient
without compromising our health without
compromising our longevity
then i'm 100 for that but today
if you were sleeping six hours or five
hours you were
doubling your risk of heart attack you
were doubling your
uh you know the risk of high blood
pressure
you were risking of dying earlier so
all that i'm not open to it and so
through technology we are trying to find
the compromise
between these two benefits
we didn't talk about food is there
anything there whether it's before you
go to sleep or when you wake up that
has an impact on sleep yeah
so definitely i mean my advice is try to
eat a couple of hours going before going
to bed
obviously the the heavier you eat the
worse
there are a bunch of studies that have
also shown that carbs
cards will help you fall asleep faster
but the quality of sleep you get
will be lower and so try to find
the right compromise the most
recommended diet is the mediterranean
diet
which is kind of balanced with also no
olive oil and
fish and avocado veggies and all that
kind of things
so definitely there is a direct
correlation
between sleep and nutrition the other
interesting correlation is if your sleep
deprived
you will start craving more junk food
there are some changes that happen in
your hormones
so there is plenty of medical evidence
of why that is happening so it's not
just you that you have this placebo fact
that
you're craving a pizza uh if last night
you slept for hours
there is really something happening in
your body and so it's really important
that you try to sleep at least seven
hours
seven to nine hours per day to really
make sure that you will also lose weight
because you will
keep your diet healthier as a
consequence of
feeling better if we fast forward
10 15 years what's the hope
for where a sleep is is it a mattress
in every bedroom and you're scanning
people's bodies or kind of what do you
think you know 10 15 years from now
is the uh kind of the holy grail yeah i
i think the concept of sleep fitness
will be
will be mass consumer right so people
will think of sleep like going to the
gym
uh we will have sleep enhancement
devices
you might call it beds but they're
really sleep enhancement devices
and preventative health
will be huge right you will be able to
know if there is anything wrong in your
body
6 months 12 months even years before you
will do today
and so you will be able to live a
healthier and longer life just because
of that
so if everyone calls it a bed which is
bed
and you call it a sleep enhancement
device which is sed
is that a an intentional uh just
changing up one letter in there
you just give me and you just give me an
idea
i love it um all right when you think
about
the one person that you would love to
have
eight sleep in their hands who's the one
person in the world that
you don't believe has the product yet
but you would love to put it in their
hands
oh that is a pretty good question um
mateo would never say i had a great
question jose had a pretty good question
though
um i don't know i mean i i i think there
are multiple people top athletes
but if i could pick one i don't have a
name but
um any doctor who is a surgeon
because he can save lives so if we can
fuel
his or her potential through better
sleep
we might be able to start saving lives
sooner uh
through them that's a great answer
i ask everyone the same three questions
and then you get asked me one to finish
but
one of the questions we already talked
about so the first question
is uh what is the most important book
that you've ever read
obviously i'm biased on that uh why do
we sleep
um and and i think the reason is this it
will open your eyes
it's not a book i i'm not affiliated
with with that so we don't work with
matthew walker
but i think um it will open your eyes
about the importance of sleep and how
sleep
can impact your longevity in your health
i i think very few people including
myself who are not aware
or not aware of that yeah it's a
fantastic book i highly recommend it
uh and if people don't want to listen to
the book you can just listen to him talk
i think he went on rogan and a couple
other podcasts
did a great job there as well um the
second question i usually ask is people
sleep routine
maybe for you what time do you go to
sleep and what time do you wake up
yeah you know i go to sleep early i you
you often
make fun of me but yeah between 9 30 and
10
i'm usually invited by 10 and i'm asleep
except when i
when i have dinner with you and felina
and you keep me up at night
so uh you don't actually go to sleep
that early 9 30 10 like i try to you
know go 10 o'clock it would be like a
good time to go to sleep but i do laugh
when uh we're trying to meet up for
dinner and and i feel guilty i'm like
hey do you want to meet at eight am i
he's gonna try to run out at 9 15 to go
home to go to sleep
i love it uh last question aliens are
you a believer or a non-believer
100 believer they exist and i will fuel
their potential
through battery sleep
[Laughter]
i have not had anyone offered to give
aliens
a sleep enhancement device you might be
the first one i will
give them an s ep
no sed device as long as they have money
and they're willing to drive revenue
then
they're in the uh the total adjustable
market right
yeah i should talk to my head of hops
and see how we can ship to them
but we will figure it out i i uh for
those that don't know keith roboy
uh from founders fund now is on is on
the board at eight sleep so
i would love to see the reaction when
you tell keith hey keith we're gonna
increase the
total adjustable market because we're
going to start to incorporate the
the alien population as customers
you know keith always says if you have a
new proposal is this going to add a zero
to your top line and i think the aliens
can add it
to the top line so he does say that
that's great
all right you can ask me one question to
finish up what do you got for me
how many hours do you sleep at night i'm
eight hours now
i used to not be i mean you know this i
used to be you know
five and a half maybe six and i was uh i
was great
i actually we're recording this today
and uh today is the day
uh one of the two days of the week where
i do a bunch of podcast recordings and i
slept seven hours and 20 minutes last
night
after being on an epic run of eight to
nine hours
uh and i was telling polina today we
went to go get lunch like i can
feel um like i am not rested which is
crazy because seven hours and 20 minutes
historically would have been
you know the equivalent of me sleeping
like eight or nine now uh
but it's uh once you get used to the
good life she said it's hard to go back
to the bad life which
i agree with actually there is one thing
i always recommend to people
and is this try to sleep one hour more
per night for one week just one week
commit for a week
and you add one hour per day to your
sleep
and after that week you tell me how you
feel
if you don't feel great i will figure it
out and and
and i give you some money back but if
you feel better
then you will decide to stick with that
yeah
i i think that you tell people that
because you know that they'll feel
better which is uh cheating
uh where can we send people if they want
to
buy a neat sleep mattress or if they
want to learn more about the company
yeah go to eight sleep dot com eight
like the number but in lacquer so
and you can also follow me on on twitter
um i mean the homepage of the website so
there is
where you can find my twitter so i was
gonna say
you uh you're up in your twitter game i
see now all of a sudden you you're uh
you're going viral
so people should definitely go follow
you uh follow you on twitter
um i i think you and my brother may be
having a competition on who can write
better threads at the time
101 with me and he's the coach so
don't don't tell people that because
then everyone's going to be dming him
asking him uh
to help them he's gonna uh come back and
say it's all mateo's fault
yeah actually so he gave me the tip and
that day
i i just published the the eight hacks
to improve your sleep we were already
working on that but it's funny because
you know
we we posted the thread like three hours
after i spoke to him
and i got almost five thousand likes and
so he texted me
saying you see i told you that credit's
worth
don't let him take credit for your hard
work he does he's been doing that
in my family for uh for literally 20
years he's been taking credit for
everyone's hard work so don't let him
steal that from you
all right thank you so much for for
coming and doing this i'm obviously a
huge fan
uh i sleep with the product every night
couldn't recommend it more to folks so
head on over to 8sleep.com and
we'll do this again in the future thank
you
thank you for having me